[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
monday
and the republican cheese has slid off
their cracker
holy actual [ __ ]
the news from the texas gop and the
fascist eric crichtons
threatening to kill dissidents of their
party
[Applause]
well i've been saying it for months and
months and months and months and months
and months
this is not gonna stop
here
they're going to continue this craziness
you just you just look at the platform
that the texas gop put out at their
little
convention this weekend which went over
like a wet fart in a white thong
holy [ __ ] and then you have eric
greitens threatening to go around and
hunt dissidents
fascism right out in the open let's go
brandon nazis like trying to one-up each
other
eric greitens puts out a [ __ ]
political ad
this morning on his twitter page
about him and a bunch of navy seals
apparently i i don't know
are going to go hunt dissidents of their
party now you got to remember who eric
greitens is before you watch before you
even watch go and watch this video and
you need to go watch this [ __ ]
before it gets taken down i've already
taken a copy of it so i have the son of
a [ __ ] as evidence
i want to be able to replay that son of
a [ __ ] to show you because you can't
look away at this this is pure red
blooded fascism folks
they are threatening to kill dissidents
they're not threatening to kill liberals
they're not threatening to kill nancy
pelosi they're not threatening to kill
chuck schumer now or joe biden for that
matter that's not what they're doing
here they're threatening to kill
dissidents inside their own party
do you know what the first thing the
nazis did when hitler took power of the
government you know the first thing he
did he killed dissidents
it's fascism right out in the open
they're let's go brandon nazis
and if you're not sure yet
rather you can convince
somebody the people that are around you
you're like are you not paying attention
to the january 6 hearings are like no i
have no idea what's going on
this is a good operation
here to show
to show them this [ __ ] ad from eric
ryden you gotta remember who eric
greitens is too
like before you go watch this video of
eric greitens you have to really
understand what kind of a [ __ ]
lunatic
eric greitens really is
he's not just some [ __ ] weird-ass
whack-a-doo running for senate in
missouri
that's not that's not the case
he's just not some [ __ ] crazy that
they got off some talent site like
lauren bobert
that's not who he is
the guy suffers from some sort some sort
of impairment on his [ __ ] cranium
he's not right in the head it's all you
need to know about this ad first off
but his history tells the story
eric greitens is the former disgraced
governor of missouri who has found out
that he
duct taped his hairdresser naked to a
treadmill in his basement
took pictures of her to use for
blackmail she doesn't perform oral sex
on him
are you listening to the words that are
coming out of my mouth
he was the governor of missouri before
that he duct taped his hairdresser
naked to a treadmill in his basement
blindfolded her and took pictures of her
to use his blackmail so that she would
perform sexual acts on him
now when he was the governor of missouri
he also also he stole a bunch of money
from a veteran's charity
but you know
forget about that
but eric greitens was investigated in
missouri not by democrats folks that's
not what happened here in missouri
the missouri legislator who was led by
republicans and the republican
investigation into eric greitens to oust
him as governor
because of these allegations against him
were republicans you know rhinos that
you might get a hunting permit for
you understand what he's not just
talking he's not just talking about the
people who believe the facts that are
being laid before us about january 6
he's talking about his political enemies
in missouri who ousted him as
governor the republicans
that's who eric greitens is
he's also
he's also a great friend of steve scabby
face bannon
hmm seems kind of convenient
we saw a video i don't know a month or
so ago with him and don jr
booker sugar jr shooting at targets
calling them liberals now he's moved
from threatening liberals with guns
to threatening dissidents inside his own
party saying if you're not maga enough
we just might come hunt you down
it really is [ __ ] hilarious
that we've heard for decades and decades
and decades and decades from these
[ __ ] second amendment bros that oh
the democrats are gonna come take your
guns they're gonna kick down your door
and come get get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
it's the republican party who are the
fascists is the republican parties who
want to take your [ __ ] rights away we
see that with the texas gop but in this
ad with eric greitens this [ __ ]
has the imagery of kicking in your door
and killing you
wake the [ __ ] up pluck your head out of
your goddamn ass and i'm not just
talking to [ __ ] to walkers
as john kennedy from louisiana will say
bunch of walkers
no i'm not talking to you wokers you
people need to show this to your family
and let me tell you something if you
show this to someone and they get all
excited about what eric greitens is
saying in this video you call them a
nazi to their face
there's nothing more fascist about this
[ __ ] video
than the absolute overt threat
to people who are not willing to think
the way you're willing to think or will
come and kick in your door and kill you
i i'm
oh eric greitens you are a true
true piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
patriots my [ __ ] ass
patriotic americans they love they do
not love america they [ __ ] hate
america
they [ __ ] hate it
they've hated it for a long goddamn time
donald trump just gave him the ability
to crawl out underneath their [ __ ]
rock and say as much
and get away with it like eric greitens
here
duct taped his hairdresser naked to a
treadmill
took photos of her
to blackmail her so she would perform
sex racks he he
and then he cuts an ad
talking about how he's gonna kill his
political enemies inside his own party
inside his own party what do you think
he's gonna do to you
what do you think eric greitens thinks
about you
if he'll kill dissidents kick down their
door
this is this is a guy running for senate
he's not running for dog catcher
he was a [ __ ] governor of a state
disgraced
his party ousted him over the
allegations
and now he's threatening them rhinos
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
and he says in the video i'm gonna play
the video here later yeah i'm gonna play
the video i don't give a [ __ ] we're
gonna play it right here
you need to see this [ __ ]
and your family needs to see this [ __ ]
everyone you know needs who can vote
needs to see this
and put it in the context of which it
which the context needs to be put
it's absolutely batshit crazy
the timeline that we're in
the people don't understand the overt
fascism that is taking place right now
in our country
i mean honestly this this
this video by eric greitens
is the manifestation of the texas gop
their new platform jesus christ they
wouldn't let the log cabin republicans
even show up to their convention they
they've they [ __ ] called
dan crenshaw and ted cruz globalist
some [ __ ] psycho some [ __ ] psycho
yelling and screaming
at dan crenshaw and ted cruz
lunatics
[ __ ] lunatics at their convention
threatening them
security had to you know get them out of
there and get them away from ted cruz
and
i mean no valid arguments are really
being made right
dan crenshaw's a globalist get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
and dan crenshaw's all upset come on dan
crenshaw you encouraged this
this ad
by eric greitens
dan crenshaw remember the one remember
the ad he did
what he when he jumped out of a [ __ ]
airplane
didn't crenshaw the guy with the [ __ ]
eye patch i patched mccain as that other
guy was calling him
he jumped out of an airplane and he was
gonna miller militar the the liberals or
some [ __ ] i don't know what it but what
the [ __ ] he was saying he's a tough guy
you know they're tough guys
eric greitens kicking in a fake door and
shooting at targets threatening liberals
and rhinos
real [ __ ] tough
but dan crenshaw dude you you
[ __ ]
you're the prelude to this [ __ ]
you are mr eye patch get a [ __ ] glass
eye
enough of the tough guy [ __ ] this is a
bunch of nonsense this [ __ ] tough guy
theater [ __ ]
you guys really do need to grow a set of
nuts eric greitens dan crenshaw ted cruz
and the rest of you [ __ ]
but here in this video we have eric
greitens threatening to kill dissidents
of their party
with guns kicking in their door
you know
forthright type [ __ ]
folks it is not it is not hyperbole to
call these people nazis anymore
that's exactly what they are that's
exactly what they want to be
they want to tell you what religion they
want to have they want to tell you who
you can and can't love
they want to take away [ __ ]
amendments from the constitution
granting people rights to vote
in texas
oh [ __ ] the voting rights act that's a
piece of [ __ ]
oh the hell with women having rights
that's a piece of [ __ ] too if they can
speak and they can vote [ __ ] them we
don't want them we do not want them in
texas and we want to secede secede from
what the nation
can you even [ __ ] imagine if texas
were to secede from the united states of
america
what kind of ramifications that would
have for the dumb [ __ ] that are
yelling and screaming we should see
come on
the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
we see we see that the country is not
buying into this nonsense
we see it
and and these these select hearings are
only increasing the pressure even more
that's why eric greitens and the texas
gop and these other [ __ ] fascists are
are
trying anything they can
because they see the mood of the country
here moving moving against these
fascists
jesus christ 60 percent of people in
this country want donald trump [ __ ]
criminally charged
of course
again i say it again and again and again
and again and again 81 million people
did not vote for joe biden
they voted against donald trump
even people who loved joe biden and
wanted him to be president voted more
against trump than they did for biden
and they're only making it worse
they're only making it worse by
narrowing their coalition
think about what they're doing every
single day
every single day
they narrow and narrow and narrow the
coalition
and not only that they put doubt into
their voters minds
because they hate democracy
they [ __ ]
hate it
and the reason why there's such hatred
for democracy is because that is the
only way that we can deliver equality
and equity in this country
is democracy yeah it's not perfect and
it's rough democracy is hard it's really
really really [ __ ] difficult
i mean jesus christ the the democratic
coalition the actual pro-democracy
coalition doesn't hardly agree on a
[ __ ] thing
you know the details of it other than we
should have some goddamn say and by we i
mean the people
me you everyone else should have a
[ __ ] say
and we shouldn't be electing people that
are threatening to kick in doors and
kill dissidents of their party
of their own ideology
this ad if you show it
to folks you know even folks you're like
i'm a die hard republican no way will i
ever vote democrat
show them this video put it in context
for them
like remember how your party that you
vote for has been talking about kicking
indoors and coming taking your guns for
decades and decades because you're a
dissident
they've been doing that because it's
projection dummy
they're projecting what they want to do
they're telling you what they're gonna
do
and they've been normalizing it through
telling you that liberals and democrats
are gonna do all this crazy stuff
they're gonna take your rights away
as we take your rats away
what do you think all this nonsense is
about a constitutional republic that's
not a democracy as if a constitutional
republic is not a democracy
[ __ ] boneheads
it's to normalize it's to normalize that
we do not live in a democracy so when it
is taken away from you you do not
realize something's being taken away
pluck your [ __ ] head
out of your ass dummy
the american evangelical delusion is
real
it's [ __ ] real and it's a cult
and this ad by eric greitens only only
strengthens
my belief
that the american evangelical
q anon
maga
ideology in this country
is a [ __ ] malignant cancer
we have
to get rid of the fascism and the only
way we do that is to vote folks and to
engage
we have to engage
not just on twitter in real [ __ ] life
with your family your friends your
community members
if you have a little bit of money
you have to give it to some of these
candidates they're gonna have to win
eric greitens
this [ __ ] psycho who put out this
goddamn video this morning
is poised to be the republican nominee
for senator
you think josh hawley is some kind of
seditious lunatic
he's not even going to hold a candle
to eric greitens in the senate
if he becomes a senator
again now is the time now right [ __ ]
now
not tomorrow not next week not next
month not after the primaries now is the
time to get engaged with politics
now you have to engage you have to talk
to folks you have to speak to them
and the and the more desperate they get
because of the evidence that is coming
from the january sixth select committee
we even see grandpa poopypants the
cheeto dust mobster
trump himself standing on stage and
basically giving a list of
the list of who's going to be standing
at the gallows when he takes back power
this weekend
i'm going to show the [ __ ] video of
him saying he's gonna pardon all the
people who helped him with a coup he had
the chance to pardon him folks he's not
gonna pardon you you dumb [ __ ]
he's not going to pardon you he'll
probably imprison you even more just
like eric greitens wants to get rid of
dissidents
wants to rid themselves
of dissidents
jesus christ
imagine a world just imagine
just imagine a world
where a democrat would have an ad where
they kick in the door
and threaten to hunt and kill the
dissidents of their party
imagine that world it's really tough i
know i know it's really rough to imagine
because democrats
by and large in this country
are
tethered to some sort of reality
some sort of normalcy
that used to exist
pre-trump
but these people live in an absoluted
absolute deluded reality they're not
tethered to it anymore and that's why
eric greitens can do an ad like this to
convince these people that yes you put
me in power we will get rid of
dissidents
because those are the people they're not
even pointing at liberals anymore like
oh own the libs no it's let's kill our
dissidents inside our party
let's kick in their doors and let's get
them because they're the problem the
dissidents in our party are the problem
because they are the threat to them at
this point
they're the real threat
imagine if the dissidents won't vote for
republicans because they're off their
[ __ ] rockers
again the gop cheese has slid off the
cracker
you just go just go read a few lines
from the texas gop's platform and look
at some of the [ __ ] pictures from
that convention this weekend holy actual
[ __ ]
why are these people so [ __ ] weird
they're [ __ ] weirdos
and that's who eric greitens is talking
to in this ad that's who he's talking to
but remember their coalition is getting
smaller and smaller
every single time they do one of these
boneheaded stunts
every time donald trump speaks every
time there's a new piece of evidence
that reveals itself of how they tried to
overthrow our government so they could
have a fascist state the more they try
to lay out a blueprint in texas in
florida for our federal government to be
a fascist state
they're not saying the
the quiet part out loud anymore they're
yelling it into a megaphone
and the more they do that
the more americans should [ __ ] pay
attention but you have to get them to
pay attention jesus christ kyrie kyrie
irving
is trending higher today because he
can't they can't decide what team he's
going to be on than eric greitens
talking about kicking in doors and
killing political
dissidents from his own party
about that for a second
this country is more worried about who
kyrie or irving is gonna play for
basketball you ain't gonna have no
[ __ ] nba you ain't gonna have no
goddamn basketball kyrie irving is not
going to play basketball if you let
these [ __ ] take power
if you let them have the reigns of power
in this country they will take it all
away from you every [ __ ] bit of it
they will come to your house they will
kick in the door and they will take it
away from you your church your school
your community
they're gonna take it away from you
that's their [ __ ] plan
again they're not just [ __ ] saying
the quiet part out loud anymore they got
a megaphone and they're yelling and
screaming what they want they want a
fourth reich
they want fascism that's what they want
they want to be able to tell you what
the [ __ ] you can and can't do and who
you can and can't do about it someone's
saying talk about gas prices oh i'll
talk about gas prices do you want these
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] who are going to
kick in your door and kill you because
you have a different idea than them to
have control over the gas prices
you want these crazy [ __ ] who
are talking about seceding from the from
the [ __ ] union in texas you want them
in control of your economy
they can't even [ __ ] they can't even
muster enough [ __ ] courage in their
goddamn p brain to say hey enough's
enough dummy
and by the way as far as gas prices are
concerned the only [ __ ] that
are doing anything about it are
democrats republicans voted no
no we want the corporations to be able
to gouge your dumb ass because the more
the corporations gouge you the more this
country will blame it on democrats and
biden and the better chance we have to
win to create a fascist state
you think you're going to have gas once
they take power
[Laughter]
you say one bad word about them and
they'll come to your house and kill you
that's what eric greitens wants to do he
wants to hunt you down and kill you if
you say one one cross word about manga
just one he'll come and kick in your
door with a [ __ ] a fleet of soldiers
to kill you
because you said one bad word about
manga you think you think you're gonna
have to worry about gas prices you are
such a stupid [ __ ] if you think
gas prices are gonna be your problem
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
pluck your head out of your goddamn ass
and realize what the hell these people
want
jesus we had a bunch of let's go brandon
nazis at pride at pride events this
weekend talking about how white
replacement and white lives matter
hiding their faces hiding their
identities
not because they're ashamed because they
know they know what the consequences are
to be outed as a white supremacist they
know
they know how unpopular this [ __ ] is
that's why they have to take power and
they have to kick in your door with a
with a band of soldiers to come kill you
that's why
because fascism is not popular it's not
it has to be forced on people and that's
what they're doing that's what they want
to do
tell your family tell your friends tell
your community members
your fellow parishioners at church
the people you talk to at your community
center
how the people you see in the grocery
store the checkout line nancy in the
checkout line who checks out your
groceries
shower
shower what they're doing
you want the guy who's gonna kick in
your door
with a bunch of soldiers
because you said one crossword about his
political party he's gonna come hunt you
down and kill you you want that guy
you want that guy in charge of your
economy you want that guy in charge of
the fed you want that guy in charge of
law enforcement
you want him to have any say over the
armed services
you want him to be in charge of gas
prices
you are out of your [ __ ] mind
you are out of your god damn ever loving
mind
i'm gonna play this video by eric
greitens when we come back from this
break
stick around do not go anywhere
i've got a lot of crazy to show you over
the weekend when we come back stick
around we'll be right back after this
break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker
convoy there's tammy by the time we
reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lid loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us like
every single weekday monday through
11 central friday pacific two full hours
every single weekday right here on
youtube twitter and twitch and now simul
casting from the midas touch facebook
page
boy do we have some news tomorrow
tomorrow is hearing number four
hearing number four day four of the
hearings and it's gonna be a day that
they're gonna talk about arizona and
georgia i think it's gonna be a very
important day i think that's why the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopypants
donald trump himself was a little
terrified over the weekend
because i think when we talk about
georgia because georgia seems to be one
of the fastest
fastest indictments that would happen
with the criminal exposure of the actual
election fraud that was taking place in
2020 after the election when donald
trump and his allies were trying to
steal it uh we see more and more
evidence of that every day with the
january 6 hearings going on and i think
tomorrow tomorrow is going to get right
at the heart of the criminality
of trump and his team in georgia i think
i think that is one of his strongest
strongest
cases to be made against him for
criminal charges
and it's probably one of the fastest way
the other thing too that a lot of people
are talking about now the the the
potential criminal liability that trump
holds in georgia
is the fact that if he does have a
pocket pardon which means the president
would pardon themselves from crimes that
they knew they committed
because if he does have a pocket pardon
that means he knew he committed crimes
which means he committed them
well
but if he does have a pocket pardon that
that that that little card doesn't work
very well
in a state court
so i think that
that uh the grand jury in georgia now
brad rant this burger seems to be a
little bit of a hostile witness he seems
that he's going to uh be appearing
before the january 6th select committee
not against his will but by subpoena
only otherwise he would not appear and
say the things he's going to say
tomorrow we'll see what the questioning
brings also
we found out over the weekend that the
former arizona speaker
who was pressured into changing the
slate of electors for the state of
arizona
by trump and his allies he's going to be
testifying as well so i think we're
going to figure out a lot of new stuff
about the state of arizona that we
didn't already know other than when the
cyber ninjas went to do their little
recount and see if they could find
bamboo ballots they actually counted
more
more votes for biden this is how this
works
this is how statistics works this is how
numbers work
when you win by a certain percentage
when you recount you generally
are
are more likely to have more votes
that's why this nonsense of audits and
everything
it doesn't make any sense to us that's
why we're still flabbergasted why
they're still spreading this big lie
it's because generally speaking
you have the situation where you'll win
by as many votes as joe biden won by
the odds are in his favor to get more
votes in a recount because that's like
that's how numbers and math like i know
they want to ban matt because they can't
really understand it maybe but
that's what happens with math
so i think tomorrow we're going to hear
a lot about georgia
specifically but also arizona
which is significant because we also
have jeannie thomas having a lot to do
with arizona and
emailing 29 representatives in arizona
trying to overthrow those electors
trying to get their own slate of
electors against the law illegal
as we find out what the pressure
campaign wasn't just towards the vice
president wasn't just going to be used
with violence with the oath keeper and
the proud boys on the vice president of
the united states and the congress
and we're going to find out eventually i
believe about the pressure that they
were putting on the doj and the court
system
but tomorrow it it feels like we're
going to find out some of the pressure
they were putting
on state legislators to
steal the election away
by breaking the law and just
usurping
the legality
of the electors
and certifying the vote inside the
states
and that's again
that's again what this eric greitens ad
is about
it's about the dissidents inside the
party
that's what it's about i mean jesus
christ donald trump was standing on
stage i think in tennessee is where he
was at this weekend
basically naming the list
of people he's gonna send to the gallows
first
if he gets power
all but saying
i'm gonna pardon the people who help me
overthrow the government and the people
who didn't and are speaking out inside
of a closed room under oath because
that's really what he's mad about bill
barr here he's pissed off at bill barr
that bill barr had to go tell the truth
under oath
with a subpoena that you didn't you did
not commit contempt to congress for me
so you are a dissident so you know
someone like i support like eric
greitens might come and kick in your
door because you're a dissident against
maga
stark imagery folks that's where we're
at though
that's where we're at i've been saying
it for months they're telling you
they're telling you who they are they're
not hiding it
and really honestly this quiet part out
loud doesn't even begin to describe it
it really is it really is a situation
where they're yelling and screaming and
into a megaphone
they want these people to know that
they're fascist
they want them to know now as americans
the good news is
is at this point our democracy is still
held together
and we can do it i'm telling you i know
there's a lot of there's a lot of
pessimistic people out there
about this
but democracy survived 2020 it can
continue to survive it's up to us we the
people are the democracy in the first
place that's what the republic is it's
made up of we the people we are the ones
who get to choose our representatives
that's what democracy is speaking that i
want to show you a little video here but
let's do this we know we go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central
with the [ __ ] list roundup so let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends i have a video i want
to show you if i can find it here
if i if i can find the video here real
quick um a friend of mine over on tick
tock troy
um he did a video on
responding to someone talking about or
constitutional republican we're not a
democracy and
some really stupid [ __ ] some really
stupid [ __ ]
about how democracies don't work and
what democracies aren't and this is why
they want to convince you dumb
[ __ ] out there that we're not a
democracy and the reason why they want
to convince you that we're not a
democracy is so when they come for you
you say oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah we get it now that's why we're
not a democracy
now this is a comment that was given to
him on tick-tock
here's troy here the comment says you
have absolutely no idea what you're
talking about and thank god we're not a
democracy it was a response to a video
that he had put out
claiming that the united states our
constitutional republic
is not a democracy watch troy absolutely
destroy this [ __ ] there's
representative democracy and there's
direct democracy direct democracy means
that citizens make laws themselves
representative democracy which is a
republic means that citizens elect their
lawmakers electing lawmakers is still a
democratic process when you're
democratically electing your lawmakers
you live in a democracy i hate to
[ __ ] break it to you if the
representatives that are making your
laws are beholden to the citizens you're
a democracy
dem means people occupy means power
democracy means people power any
government that has the sovereignty of
citizens is a [ __ ] democracy it would
be totally trivial to be arguing these
definitions with you [ __ ] people
except for how dangerous this philosophy
is as far as i can tell this whole not a
democracy thing only started about 10
years ago this is a brand new [ __ ]
movement it kind of started in the tea
party era which is when everything in
this country started to go downhill it's
the basis for magga it's the basis for
donald trump what's your reason for
thinking that we're not a democracy
because of the electoral college because
of the senate
because you don't think majority rules
majority rules in every election at
every office at every level of our
society except for the president
constitutionally the senate is majority
rule the filibuster which requires 60
votes to end debate
is an arbitrary rule that the senate
made up the filibuster is not in the
constitution the constitution says 51
votes passes the senate even the
presidency is technically majority rules
because you need a majority of the
electoral college to win but if these
[ __ ] fascists can use
uh
majority doesn't rule as some sort of uh
wedge into we're not a democracy
then you start getting we're not a
democracy circling around in your little
fascist brain and that makes it that
much easier for when one person say oh i
don't know
initiates a coup against our government
and installs themselves as dictator for
life and oh look it has an army of you
little fascist clones all ready to stand
up and say we're not a democracy when
people protest and say that our
democracy is dying if you don't think
we're a democracy you won't defend our
democracy which is exactly what they
[ __ ] want
and there you have it uh troy i'm gonna
bring in uh gabe sanchez gabe i i know
you you know troy on tic tac uh he got
there pretty well to one of his troll
there's several times troy's done a
video but i found this one
particularly very very very pointed
the reason why these republicans like
eric greitens this morning releasing
this ad where he basically said i'm
going we're going to break in the door
and kill dissidents
i mean that's what he's projecting here
is right we are literally if you say
anything against or you are not a 100
backing manga we will kick in your door
and we will kill you um and we will do
it with troops and guns they're gonna
they're gonna come after you
i think troy gets at the point here when
he's like
they're convincing you that this isn't a
democracy so when they make it not a
democracy you're like yeah we never
lived in a democracy in the first place
right
yeah i mean i think i think that you
know the last point is like if you don't
acknowledge it you don't respect it you
don't actually believe it's real thing
then why would you ever defend it right
and that's exactly what they want if the
thing never existed there was nothing to
defend
or actually you know um
believe in in the first place right and
so if it never existed then it was never
a problem
and that's exactly what they want
well i mean uh here here goes to another
video from from a january 6 or now we
seen the the former president of the
united states stand on stage this
weekend and say he was going to pardon
all the people involved in january 6
which he already had the chance to do
that he's [ __ ] lying to him again
he's like good guys guys guys give me
more money right
when i become president in 2024 you know
uh i will pardon you and these guys some
of these people are probably dumb as
[ __ ] like yeah i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna plead guilty i'm gonna let this
[ __ ] go to trial and it's like you
just [ __ ] yourself over
well i mean that's listen to this guy
here this guy is on trial i forget his
name off hand here but he's a january
sixer and he's facing some hard time
listen what he tells two thousand mules
uh dinesh d'souza this is
this is really really again they're
picking up the megaphone and they're
saying the quad they're not it's not
quiet part anymore yelling and screaming
into a megaphone listen to this a little
bit about just the experience of
enduring it
yeah thank you for that question it's
important that the american people
realize that there's human rights
atrocities happening to political
prisoners um i mean just miles away from
our own capital they're trying to grind
us down and break us down to take and if
you see here danessa sousa even on his
show has j6 political prisoners right
political prisoner it really again not
insurrectionist not seditionist not
traitor that's right again it is it is
this mindset it is this mindset that
only people who adhere to the proper
ideology the proper ideas the one thing
you know
that the party that says free speech
they mean you're free to speak the way
we want you to speak right right you're
free to speak the way we want you to
speak you're not you do not have the
freedom of speech you you definitely do
not have the freedom of speech because
donald trump went after his political
rivals and bill barr and mike pence at
the same rally where he said he would
[ __ ] pardon jake lang here right but
but they believe they believe somehow
that them
them overturning our constitution and
really trying to overthrow our
government rather they were delusional
in that effort or not somehow they're
political prisoners here and this jake
lang is going to go to prison for a long
time because he won't take a plea deal
or listen to what he says about the deal
these horrible plea deals um
six seven my plea deal that they offered
me was 108 months that's over nine years
um in prison for defending my
constitution and so they're sticking us
in these squalid conditions to um break
us down to make us lose a conviction um
to basically make us government lap dogs
who are begging for a plea deal and i'm
here to tell you that
the spirit of god is is alive oh there
you go there you go
there you go it's the it's the crystal
fascist american evangelical um ideology
that is that is thumping through these
yeah the other thing here is you know
he's
he's trying to make the argument that uh
that
nine months you know oh i'm not gonna
take the or the nine year deal i'm not
gonna take the nine year deal right
which in all like in reality he's not
gonna get the full nine years like he'll
probably get off on shorter term because
overpopulation or because of good
behavior or whatever like he probably
actually won't see the full nine years
but the fact that that's the minimum
right now
only boots it to be worse for him going
forward if he's not willing to accept
the minimum because they're like hey
listen you uh did a lot of illegal stuff
you're
in involved in this conspiracy of
sedition
uh you broke into the capital you caused
this destruction as a result these
people were harmed these people died um
it's all tied back to you know your
involvement right
and the fact that he is unwilling to
accept nine years and again it probably
would be even less than nine years if he
were to even like say hey i know some
info on some other people but he's
unwilling to do that which means that
when he goes to trial
it's going to be really bad for him well
gabe it would be it would be kind of
frightening if you were
if you actually knew a lot of
information about some of the people
that were involved in planning january
6th right when you have people like eric
greitens threatening to kick in your
door and kill you with guns and soldiers
if you're a dissident to maga right i
mean this is this is the this is and
here you go here's donald trump standing
on stage giving his warning
to bill barr and mike pence listen to
this i never called mike pence a wimp i
never called him a wimp
again he's called him a [ __ ] yeah and
then a lot of people won't say it i'll
say it on here because i don't give a
[ __ ]
donald trump called mike pence a [ __ ]
and the reason why he did is because
donald trump is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and he's
threatening him here this takes one to
no one right well then
it might and here's the thing is if you
guys go watch michael cohen decoded some
of donald trump's language and a lot of
people think oh donald trump's just
being childish when he says stuff like
oh well you're not a friend and these
are overt threats this is the language
that mob bosses use to say oh those are
those are nice those are nice children
it would be ashamed if anything happened
to him which we're gonna get to we're
gonna get to with adam kinzinger a
letter that was written to him and his
family here but listen to the the
not so obvious threats that donald trump
is giving to bill barr and mike pence
here mike pence
had a chance to be great
he had a chance to be great he's not
great anymore
so what am i going to do to make him not
great if i'm in power a chance to be
frankly historic historic
but just like bill barr and the rest of
these weak people there you go these
weak people and he's talking about all
you know what's funny about that is bill
steffen
yeah may remember this guy his wife was
supposed to be in labor that's why he
couldn't testify still haven't seen a
photo i have not seen a baby you know
you know who still helps run manga
campaigns you know who still helps them
run manga campaigns bill and i bet he
was told that if he goes and he
testifies you better find a way out of
this bill yeah you better find a way out
because all that money you're making
those political campaigns boy it would
be a shame to something happen to it
let's keep listening
mike and i say it sadly because i like
them
but mike did not have the courage
to act
bill barr was afraid of certain things
and you know what they were
uh what were they you know
we know what they would he's saying he's
literally saying the stuff that the
january 6 select committee's telling you
is true it's true i did want to
overthrow the government i did want to
do that and these weak people wouldn't
do that that's what he's saying he's
right he's not saying all they're weak
because they went and they told lies
about me that's not what he's saying
he's saying they told the truth that you
heard you heard the truth and i tried to
overthrow the government and they
wouldn't help me do it so that makes
them [ __ ] and that makes them weak i
mean the other thing too is you know
ignoring the fact that every person
who's been in this deposition has been
under oath okay
they have been telling the truth
or else they have consequences if they
lie perjury you know
100 of billboard could have lied he
would have lied but oh yeah the one
moment that proves to me that bill barr
had to go back and study all his notes
because he was taking notes during this
time
is the moment where he's like there are
three instances that i can recall
meaning there's three instances in his
notes where he talked to the president
about overturning the election so that's
why he said that i can recall meaning i
went back and looked at all my notes and
those are the ones in there anything
else outside those notes i'm not going
to tell you because it might look even
worse right like he's only telling you
what he has to do he's like i remember
the moments in which i was officially
called in right exactly not the
hallway talk or the bathroom chat or
whatever the grabber by the [ __ ] thing
you know where you grab the united
states by the [ __ ] and take it over you
know because that's what that's what
powerful people can do they let you do
that kind of stuff right they let you do
that kind of stuff jesus christ
please don't impeach me don't impeach me
billboard please i said what's wrong
with being impeached i got to preach
twice and my poll numbers went up what's
wrong with doing crime they love it when
you do crime geez what's the big deal
when you commit crime they love you they
love when you commit crime right
fantastic it's fantastic
they love it and they love they love
when you talk about all kinds of crazy
ass [ __ ] even at the texas gop did you
see this picture from the
i feel like this rambo trump combo thing
has been around for years and it's very
very weird it's right
it's it is so odd that someone goes oh
you know what gets my [ __ ] loins
going
you know what [ __ ] gets me going when
i start tubing and lubing man is when
i put [ __ ]
his head trump's head on rambo's body
you're right nothing's made nothing's
made the world drier
oh my god less moisturizing this has
been shapiro that was [ __ ] than this
cut out here oh my god you look at this
and it's like the person who made this
one was like yeah this shitty photo of
trump
this'll do all right i'm gonna cuz i
didn't even take like a good yeah
there's tons of very good like high
quality photos there's like a [ __ ] in
this he looks like a [ __ ] he's like
he totally looks like a [ __ ] but it's
like when people are like oh my god let
me caress these muscles these cardboard
muscles i mean you know this is the same
type of [ __ ] that marjorie taylor green
was [ __ ]
cuddling trump's balls the cardboard
ball cut out
that
little meeting she was at when she was
like oh trump oh yeah let me let me
grind my [ __ ] body and touch his
balls like i'm a [ __ ] weirdo
well to give context this cutout is from
in front of like a i don't know it's
called like patriot phone or some [ __ ]
some stupid [ __ ] grift right they're
saying that it's the most christian
phone company or some [ __ ] i don't know
because this is but this is their
evidence this is your evidence that
they're the most patriotic the most
christian company is they've got a
cardboard cutout of sylvester stallone
with a little [ __ ] face pasted on to it
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna call it as
it is right if trump had the body and
actually look like [ __ ] rambo then
they would actually have a photo of
trump looking like [ __ ] rambo right
but when you have to put someone's face
on someone else's body
you [ __ ] lost
right
it's also [ __ ] weird also there seems
to be this very weird fascination with
sir vessel stallone around putting his
face on [ __ ] uh rambo and rocky like
it's very weird you guys are very
obsessed it's a cult it is very [ __ ]
odd well that's like that's like this
weekend well that's like this weekend
joe biden he he's bicycling right
because our our president right now our
current president right now can actually
get on a bike and ride it without his
ass swallowing his seat i mean i mean
even even donald trump but this [ __ ]
whatever this nazi rally was in
tennessee admits that he can ride he
doesn't ride a bicycle well he said he
said i'm never gonna did he say he can't
or he's not i'm never gonna get promised
he pledged you'll never he'll never get
near which also i don't know i don't
know if you remember this but eric trump
was on fox news and was also [ __ ] on
biden previously and he was riding him
you know the same type of bike
and eric trump was like oh this what is
he riding a beach cruiser what a loser
and i'm like
maybe one eric trump always wanted a
bike and because trump could never ride
a bike and didn't know how to
he never got one for his kids eric and
don junior can't ride bikes oh 100
percent they have to have 100 percent
that's what it is that's why they're so
pissed off that biden fell and they hit
a curb and he fell
yeah it looks because i guarantee if
they did get a bike and they fall off
the bike that trump at that one moment
made fun of them and they never went to
the bike ever again and now they cannot
train their kids how to ride a bike so
what do they do they either rely on
their wives or they rely on some hired
help of some sort maybe go to craigslist
find themselves some sort of ad where
they can get someone to actually teach
their kids how to ride a bike but
growing up i guarantee they didn't have
a bike and if they did have a bike and
they fell off trump made fun of them 100
100 percent his bike
had training wheels and he never got
over the training well someone posted
this picture i'm not sure who it was
yeah um and they said name is gabe
sanchez
i mean tell me tell me this guy is not
trump i dwelt
gabe sanchez here says gonna tell my
kids this was trump on a bicycle um
it's not far off i mean really honestly
looks i mean
i mean the face
it like you didn't have to you didn't
even necessarily i didn't
i did not i did not do anything to this
phone i just found this photo what is
this this was this was stock photography
yeah yeah i found it and i was like no
trump this is trump models stock
photography he must be really desperate
for [ __ ] money i mean he is strapped
for ken the next thing you're gonna find
is he's gonna be doing only fans and i
guarantee
people put money for that [ __ ] all of
his followers they'll [ __ ] double
mortgage on their house i just you know
this bicycle is actual this is a an
actual adult-sized bicycle that's just
his ass has swallowed it apparently yeah
yeah no it's [ __ ]
huge
he is
huge oh my god i think it's hilarious i
think it's hilarious so like oh joe bad
you can't ride a bicycle like no he
actually can ride a bicycle like that's
what you were watching
it's because he got his ass on a bicycle
and he rides one frequently is the
reason why he'd fall off one trump would
never fall off a bicycle he would never
[ __ ] the reason why he couldn't get his
fat ass on one right yeah i mean it's
the same it's the same thing like
democracy you can't defend it if there
was never
so you could never fall off a bike if
there was never a bike to get on to
begin with that's right well it seems
like um he's he's scared of more than
just bicycles he's scared of shackles
this interview i'm not sure what kind of
trader news network this is some kind of
i don't know some kind of trader show
here donald trump calls it in he calls
it in because he's probably he probably
doesn't have his hair done and his
makeup done to appear on tv on this one
so he's phoned it in here but this guy
talks about shackles in mar-a-lago and
i'm like whoa you're talking my language
here this is the kind of [ __ ] i like to
hear let's listen to what this guy says
about arresting trump at mar-a-lago
let's hear this and demonize you and
when they arrest the peter navarro
who's next you are they going to try to
take you out of mar-a-lago in shackles
this is insanity that we're allowing
this to happen
uh-huh what's going on has never been
seen in this country before
nobody's ever seen anything he's like in
shackle what do you know something i
don't know
yeah he's like
like when you say phone it in he
literally phoned this interview in as
soon as i saw this uh this this clip
being shared online
and he goes
i was like wow man this guy is hitting
rock bottom he's either [ __ ] drugged
out on adderall or he is you know uh
[ __ ] himself uh uh with you know in
a full of depends but i look at him and
i'm just like
like it doesn't even he doesn't even i
don't even know man this guy is is a
complete buffoon right and is now using
any opportunity you know in addition to
his rage truthing on truth social
but he just like from bed he's like uh
uh-huh yeah what do you say the other
day uh i want equal time like dude he
said i demanded equal talk yeah i bet
yeah
right i bet there would be no one more
excited about [ __ ] donald trump
sitting across from her under oath than
[ __ ] liz cheney she would absolutely
eat his [ __ ] lunch like just destroy
donald trump i mean if he wants you know
i'm trying to by the end trying by the
end of the day to finish is what was
that uh which is like a recap right i
mean there was so much that happened
between days one and three there there
literally is so much i have to decide
[ __ ] you you can't even remember at this
point
there's also stuff i can't even i'm just
like i can't even talk about that
because it's gonna be so long so i'm
trying to wrap that up by the end of the
day and get so everyone who's listening
uh the new
the newest what was that is going to be
a recap of
day one through three on the january 6th
select earrings exactly so uh yeah i
look at that and i and i'm just like oh
my god yeah there's so much stuff that
has to be covered but
uh trump is rage truthing as i'll call
it because that's how they use the term
they're like oh did you read truth did
you did you quote truth did you [ __ ]
i don't even know what they don't even
know what it's called they're like oh
man these are i got 42 retreats on this
thing and it's like this is so [ __ ]
they didn't think that through oh no not
at all not at all man well they don't
think anything so anyway this is a
drugged out trump phoning it in
half-assing this interview
uh really attempting to
uh to win people over to tell them how
this is total [ __ ] well all the tens
of people watching this oh yeah yeah
whatever this was anything like it you
write about navarro but there are others
also that went through hell
and uh and went through hell for no
reason these are good people in almost
all cases but in many cases these are
very good people these are
it's really funny when he's like some
maybe i don't know but in like most
cases they're really really aren't they
even talking about he's like no no the
criminals that were trying to take away
your government trying to take away your
democracy trying to usurp your vote they
were kind i mean maybe kind of good i
mean you know history will probably tell
a different story but you know
things
right
i mean just total [ __ ] word salad man
yeah and they're looking to destroy him
it is so serious this whole thing and
you know i'm at the forefront i'm proud
to be at the forefront
what what
what is that he's at the forefront of
what
the crime like yeah yeah
yeah we we're watching the hearing he's
like i'm at the forefront i'm at the
forefront of this whole [ __ ] coup
right one people they're gonna they're
gonna they can't stop talking about me
i'm the forefront of their mouths i am
the forefront of their brain like what
is he the forefront of what i exactly i
don't know
but he's probably like any day now
they're gonna say that i was the one
that did it all it was um it was all me
i did all this i should get all the
credit like yeah that's what we're
saying dummy the whole thing's dedicated
to you [ __ ]
we've caught them
but we need some strength on the
republican side look bill barr
he was afraid to do anything see there's
there's the there's the whole eric
greitens kicking in your door for
dissidents thing we need to do something
what do you mean what do you mean you
know the thing like with all these
people whether you're like you know eric
grimes dude got chill chill i wasn't
saying literally kicking the door i was
saying like metaphorically kicking the
door and replace these [ __ ] and shoot
their heads off you know it's like whoa
dude you need to chill out you clearly
are dealing with some [ __ ]
okay
but it's that type of rhetoric you know
when they're like oh i didn't mean
literally you know it's like fox news
like oh no no anyone who would be sane
wouldn't actually take us seriously
well you heard you heard the actual
insurrection that happened gabe oh
yeah this is this is really breaking
news and important because forget about
the insurrection that happened on
january 6 where they tried to overturn
our constitution apparently triumph the
insult comic dog
tried to go commit comedy on the capitol
and that is a huge i mean you know it's
cold bears comedy coup baby you know
it's actually you know colbert's comedy
coup
i might i might say that's actually a
great name for just a show itself right
like like a
um a show of comics you know anyone with
other entertainment you know just a just
a variety show really
i i mean they could actually probably
make something of it but
i would totally here's the thing they're
like oh my god the insurrection do it's
like i hope that the right understands
how much material they literally just
handed over
to colbert and his team right well i
mean because it's it
they were they were arrested apparently
because they didn't have the proper
passes in the where they were at like
where they were they weren't smearing
[ __ ] on the walls right right right well
it might have been shitty comedy
although triumph the insult comic dog is
normally good comedy it's normally good
comedy um it's uh have you ever seen the
clip of uh
triumph the insult comic dog handing ted
cruz's ass like literally like tearing
it off and handing it to him no
if we can find it we'll um we'll play it
here but you said according to
republicans stephen colbert
and his capital comedy coup
is a real problem in america welcome to
idiocracy i mean this is this is tucker
carlson
so this is almost beyond belief but just
before this show where we learned that
last night producers for stephen
colbert's show on cbs
committed insurrection at the united
states capital
what he they committed what
like literally there is a definition
there is a definition gabe of
insurrection like these things these
words you can go dust off the dictionary
or just pick up your phone i mean most
people have a phone you can google the
definition to a word to go with the
definition oh you have to do that would
even say that most of these people who
are claiming that it's a common or it's
a it's an actual insurrection and
colbert was trying to overthrow the
government with five writers or how how
many ever people that were there at the
capitol
don't actually own a dictionary
they don't even know what one is right
you say dictionary and they say what
about my dick what what who's got a
bigger dick than me wait who said i had
a small dick right who's that you're
like hey just look it up in the
dictionary how dare you talk about my
small dick well speed that's the type of
response speaking of small dick energy
did you see these uh these
nazis in tennessee there they were
they've been around the country here it
seems like a patriot front type thing um
spotted just now tennessee holler had
races heading towards franklin's june t
2020 celebration in city of franklin so
there so you know yesterday was
juneteenth today is the federal holiday
of jujin because it's a monday but
yesterday was was the 19th of june so
that's juneteenth and we all know now
that that it's a federal holiday we know
what juneteed means that was the very
last day
that that
slaves in this country actually found
out that they were free that was the day
in galveston texas
of all places but you see this picture
here of these you talk about small dick
energy here look at these guys with
these signs that say white lives matter
stop white replacement they hate you for
being this is really small dick energy
gabe and the reason the reason why i
really say it's small dick energy
because i'm not opposed
to
fragile white males having a right to
hold up a sign that says really stupid
[ __ ] right i actually think
that we should encourage more of these
dumb [ __ ] to hold up these
signs but they fail to forget that
freedom of speech generally what it
means is not freedom of anonymity right
they want to be anonymous here because
during the pandemic i'm sure every one
of these [ __ ] said stuff like oh mask or
to make you you know to for is a the
government's way to control you right
and it's their way to make you
delusional and it's going to make you
more sick and mass caused coven but here
we see these
these boneheads and they all you know to
to all fairness they all ordered the
exact same mask off amazon so they did a
a decent job of course we got it in bulk
you know they helped uh jeff bezos or
whoever was selling those masks actually
you know funny that you mentioned small
dick energy and i don't know if this is
where you were going with this
but i just sent you a link for a photo
no i don't know if this is the actual
photo of the original and this is the
photoshop one
but i don't know it seems like the
actual signs that they're holding are
telling the truth okay well let me let
me pull that before i do that i want to
point out this guy that's
see this guy in the red sunglasses here
that's got his face hidden because he
doesn't want the internet to know his
identity he said they hate you for being
white is the sign he's holding look on
his look what he's wearing gabe do you
see on his pants he's wearing kneepads
why in the world why in the world if
you're in a peaceful protest would you
have to wear knee pads it seems like
maybe he to get to the front of the line
area he had to use those knee pads maybe
i'm just can you sorry the guy in the
can you go back to that photo yeah the
guy on the left can you zoom in are
those cowboy boots or those military
boots i i'm not sure and they're they're
old they're really worn out like justin
style boots or something you know it's
um
they really they really it's a lot of
small dick energy he is carrying his
water here i mean you don't want to get
dehydrated when you're when you're you
know participating in a racist protest
here right you're right no yeah you
really want to you don't want to get
parched i mean
for crying out loud
oh boy he's [ __ ] racist i tell you
what
and it never ceases to amaze me so
what's this what's this picture i'm
gonna look at i'm almost oh well just
you know take a look at the photo and i
feel like everyone will understand
exactly the message that these
these white supremacists these nazis are
trying to you know be truthful about you
see so ryan's [ __ ] here um so you got to
look up you got to go up to the first
one first scroll up
oh okay so this is okay so this is this
is ryan's first tweet he says wake up
white people the supremacists are out
and proud and here's
here's these guys i don't see the
kneepad guy he must have not had got on
his knee pads to get into the front of
the line yet right here right this must
have been before they got to that
intersection or the kneepad guy because
it looks like this uh well this guy's
got boots with his pants tucked in but
it looks like he looks like uggs yeah
something and the sign says we must
secure the existence of our people in
the future for white children okay stop
white replacement wake up white man
stop white replacement really racist
[ __ ] here yeah on these signs
but uh he also goes on to say
ah
maybe at i am gabe sanchez fixed it for
us what did you write on these signs
what did you write on these signs
um this may be photoshopped it probably
isn't um this is probably what they
actually meant to have on these signs
this one says no women will date me
because i'm a racist and because my dick
is small well i mean he's just outright
saying it um this one he seems to have a
sign saying i have a very small penis
and then i also have a small dick i am
very insecure
you know
i'm just i'm just saying i'm just saying
these these seem to be the real thing
well it seems to be a pattern with uh
these fascists and these republicans
because
you look at the texas gop and their
little platform they had out oh my god
they
they are very insecure about their
sexuality oh 100
i mean they are completely threatened by
anyone
in anything like oh
my whiteness like who in the [ __ ] thinks
whiteness is right
nobody [ __ ] cares about you man like
christmas come on yeah i mean
that's also the problem is like these
people are like oh no man oh no one
loves me
it's like maybe you're just not a good
person people really don't give a [ __ ]
about you and that's what that was your
own you know that was the consequence of
your actions you decided to hold up a
[ __ ] sign that said uh white lives
matter white replacement theory and
white men wake up when everyone else is
like you guys are [ __ ] idiots and i
hope to god you get bread out of
existence
because any more of you [ __ ]
are gonna hurt the the world that we
live in so yeah i photoshopped a [ __ ]
photo but it was really only telling the
truth of what they're really thinking
well right it's just it's just what
they're actually projecting right
exactly
it's like that it's like you know the
movie of um
they uh they live right where you have
the sunglasses and you lift up and
you're like oh this is the world that is
presented before me and i put the
sunglasses down and then i see the
actual world
that's what happens you put the
sunglasses down and you actually see
the uh the signs that there so they can
do whatever they want they can wear
their knee pads they can wear their uggs
you know they can be all tough and wear
their [ __ ] skeleton masks
but those little [ __ ] boys can't get
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they've got little
bunch of [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] um you
know and they're always they're always
focused on someone else's genitalia you
know so it's not surprising that they're
projecting about their small penises
weird because they can't stop talking
about gender even in the gop
platform
this weekend
and i i found this video on tick tock
but i said when a republican can't stop
talking about gender just say this
and this is a it's only 13 seconds it's
not very long but
listen up here when someone says
anything about gender or bathrooms or
any of this groomer stuff
about gender just just listen to what
you should say
you're gonna let the government assign
your gender
okay
because there's nothing
there's nothing more that terrifies
absolutely terrifies these people than
the word government i mean they are
terrified of the word government and uh
she puts it in and plain
okay
okay yeah you're gonna let the
government assign your gender okay yeah
what a [ __ ] conformist oh my god oh
speaking of the government if we let
these people have control what they're
gonna do uh brings me to the eric
greitens video here i want everyone to
know that um you should not look away
this is very important i'm i'm actually
surprised that twitter hasn't taken this
video down yet are you i mean i'm
surprised this thing's still up um this
is i don't i don't i'm not sure what to
think of this video i mean like i know
what to think of this video but i look
at it and i say
you know they're going to claim again
well dude it's just a metaphor just like
uh symbolism and uh
you know i don't really mean to say go
in and [ __ ] shoot these people
[ __ ]
why first off this first scene here
um with eric greitens in his safari
shirt which i i think that's kind of
funny um and he's kind of he's got a
shotgun here he doesn't actually have an
assault rifle so i think even even even
the people who are making this video is
like hey i don't think we can do the
whole assault rifle thing right like are
you carrying this are like that's even
more like
threatening you're threatening to kill
your political your political rivals
because you know ultimately just in the
last few years since trump took office
these second amendment bros went from oh
it's our right to protect ourselves uh
we have to hunt with these things and
we've even seen this nonsense in the
congress or some of these senators like
we use it to shoot prairie dogs and wild
hogs and we have an ar-15 right exactly
right so they they they always go back
to the hunting right
but here eric greitens is talking about
hunting a specific
type of
thing
that might or might not have the same
[Music]
name and sound as an actual animal but
he's not actually talking about the
animal here because you wouldn't find
um
this type of animal and what appears to
be some sort of
missouri trailer park or something here
i'm not sure exactly where eric greitens
is here maybe he has a secret house that
he has where he ties up more people and
duct tapes than to a treadmill naked in
a basement i don't know maybe that's
what he does i have no idea this [ __ ]
scumbag but even in the very first shot
of this where he's holding a shotgun
here instead of an assault rifle it
really does say that they knew what
message they were sending so they made
sure to be very careful about the gun he
was holding and even the safari shirt
he's wearing but watch what happens when
he just the first words that start to
come out of his mouth
i'm eric greitens navy seal and today
okay first off
eric greitens and i'm i'm a navy seal
right so already already he's presenting
the fact that he
he is an expert right and most the time
and a lot of people are talking about
this on twitter when someone is a navy
seal they don't generally like yeah yeah
they don't generally come out with it
like that's
a certain degree of
energy i mean what this is definitely
small dick energy on eric greitens but
it's also it's
outright fascism here because he's
presenting himself as the as a as
someone who is with the military and
then watch what happens
when it cuts to the scene of the front
door who's standing there and who bust
in the door with him i think that's very
important hey we're going rhino hunting
the rhino
now if you go back here and you look at
the uh the mailbox here
uh the mailbox here obviously it is um
it looks like little pieces of paper
whoever cut out and paste it on this i
mean they didn't even do a good job i
mean the arts department really they
really phoned it in on this one right
this is this is [ __ ] second rate here
folks number one again this neighborhood
i don't know this house
looks kind of abandoned because the
mailbox is all beat up i guess maybe
that's the imagery here that they're
trying to present but they couldn't even
go as far as having a decent art
department they they cut out and paste
you know little paper letters on the
mailbox here it's like a ransom note
yeah [ __ ] idiot um but he's saying
rhino and he's trying to make people
think that it's like the animal rhino
right right but which is misspelled
right if they were to go that route so
either they're [ __ ] idiots
or they're [ __ ] idiots right like
there's only two ways out of this either
you're going to say oh man
we meant rhinos like the animal they're
gonna be like what kind of [ __ ]
rhinos in a house and like i don't know
dude it's missouri right i mean you tell
me tony but now look at this in your
house there are no i not that i know
not that i i've never been i've never
been to anyone's house and there be a
rhino inside like the animal right yeah
you look at this and they're like well
you spelled rhino rino as if it was
republicans in name only because no no
no we met rhino and they're like well
it's spelled r-h-i-n-o and they're like
oh oh my bad and like okay you're
[ __ ] dumb right or
they said no no we met rhino like
republicans and it's like okay you're
[ __ ] dumb that the craziest part here
is
the context is that eric greitens is
running in a primary race to become the
republican nominee for senator in
missouri
and he thinks the best approach
is to threaten other republicans who
he's trying to court their votes right
to threaten to kick in their door and
kill them because watch what happens
when he talks about what he's going to
do to people who are dissidents the
rhino feeds on corruption and is marked
by the stripes of cowardice
[Music]
join the maggot crew get a rhino hunting
permit there's no bagging limit no
tagging limit and it doesn't expire
until we save our country
clearly he's threatening dissidents of
maga yeah
clearly and if you go back
you see these military these people in
these military uniforms that's why he
said the navy seal thing at first
because he's clearly saying i'm going to
take over the government we're going to
bring the military because they're
wearing they're wearing united states
flags on these uniforms
he is telling you missourians and
americans and anyone in this country
that eric greitens wants to use the
military
to beat in your door if you are a
political dissident and come and kill
you
that's what he's saying hunting
no bagging limit no tagging limit anyone
who's ever hunted yeah white-tailed deer
or turkey knows that to get a tag when
you get a tag that tag is what you use
to say i killed only the amount of
wildlife that i was supposed to kill
because you're
even
even even these 2a uh
numbskulls these ninja boop nazis can't
even admit that even their guns that
they use to go hunt with that is
regulated of how many
animals they can kill during a certain
time of the year in most states but here
eric greitens is clean
kill them all
right he's clearly saying here he wants
to kill dissidents and he'll beat in
your door with the military if you just
just give him the power to do that right
this isn't fascist at all gabe not fat
not
maybe just uh he's like no knocking
warrants i'm busting through this
[ __ ] door right with the military
with the military like he's literally
saying he's gonna use federal power
these people who are always like oh the
government's gonna come take your guns
like literally what eric greitens is
telling you here is he's gonna use his
government power to get the military to
come kick in your [ __ ] door the [ __ ]
they have been threatening the democrats
will do for decades and decades and
decades right over guns now they're
saying and he's not saying we're going
to come get liberals because we all know
that's what they're going to that's yeah
yeah
well he he said it he said it with well
yeah he was with donald trump jr you're
right now he's not even saying just
liberals we're gonna come after you
if you dissent
from maga just one false word against
maga and we'll come kicking we'll use
the military we'll use our federal power
the government will come kicking your
door and we will hunt you and we will
tag you
and we will bag you he's saying he will
kill
maga dissidents it is
oh i can't even it's
i want to read what uh
shannon watts wrote here because she did
write something here she said um after a
former missouri governor she should say
disgraced here by the way uh missouri
governor eric greitens was charged with
violent sexual misconduct his ex-wife
says he bought and hid a gun
he also threatened to shoot himself
unless she supported him publicly now
he's threatened to kill his political
opponents this is all this is all part
of that white privilege gun culture
nonsense
the same [ __ ] that these
that these white
white replacement ninja poop nazi let's
go brandon types
are talking about on the street corner
wearing their knee pads and their skull
mask
same [ __ ] [ __ ] um rachel bittikoffer
you know one of our our favorite
political strategist here i want to read
a tweet by her she says this is
this is the real ad known creepazoid
republican eric greitens is using for
his missouri senate primary this is a
real ad now i doubt after this
after this uh twitter storm that's
happening around this attitude it does
it says right there right it doesn't say
this tweet violated the twitter rules of
abusive behavior oh it's so it's down
it's down now so so it is down folks
well it's it's not down i mean oh okay
yeah yeah okay so um but uh rachel goes
on to say here dude is a walking talking
poster trial a child for red flags she
points out a really really important
thing here
basically the reason why we need red
flag laws in this country are for people
like eric greitens right who were making
videos to post around the internet and
on tv they're gonna pay to put these
things on tv saying he's going to kill
political dissidents our political
opponents right that the people who
don't agree with him who disagree with
maga we're going to come and we're going
to kill you with guns
this is this is [ __ ] the reason why
we need to have mental health care in
this country and we need it fast
i mean eric greitens could have used
mental health care years ago
unfortunately now i mean he suffers from
some sort of
a wacky thing that has got his his
his wires crossed in his brain some of
the [ __ ] that he's done
he is absolutely out of his mind
to think that this is okay for this kind
of political ad the craziest part is is
there's people uh i'm sure in the
comments just loving this video oh yeah
but you see here i love it
the news is here is that uh twitter has
it's at to some degree censored this
video it says this again it says this
tweet violated the twitter rules about
abusive behavior
however twitter has determined that it
may be a public public's interest for
the tweet to remain accessible and i
think what twitter's saying here is hey
you need to come look at this
you need to come look at this goddamn
thing and see what these people are
doing
yeah do not look away like we say here
do not look away you have to come see
this
because here's another here's another
crazy thing that's happened over the
weekend uh adam kinzinger you know i i
don't really agree with adam kings yeah
i really don't even
think that you know we should hail him
quite as the hero as some people want i
mean just because you just because
you're willing to tell the truth that
makes you that's not what a hero is
and and adam kinzinger as much as he is
uh fending off threats here um because
that's what this letter shows which is
really despicable right
i'm not encouraging anyone on our side
to s to say anything but what you
actually think against adam kinzinger
like the the
the ideas that he has
aren't that great advertising your ideas
suck
but the difference between adam
kinzinger here and liz cheney even the
difference between those two is adam
kinzinger has been speaking out about
against trump for a long time
way longer than liz cheney was um but in
this in this letter here that i'm gonna
show
uh he he tweets here is the letter
addressed to my wife sent to my home
threatening the life of my family
the darkness is spreading
uh courteous of the cowardly leaders
fearful of truth
is this what you want gop pastors he's
asking the question
um
i guess his wife's name is soph sophia
is that is that right i think that's who
this is addressing uh i'm i'm guessing
if it's a dresser i don't know his
wife's name now um the letter here the
picture of the letter here that he
posted you are a stupid and he blanked
out this word but it's almost
recognizable it seems like it says [ __ ]
um of course i'm not going to censor it
here on the tony michael's podcast
that's what i'm seeing that word is but
it is censored so i can't be sure this
is you are a stupid
blank
um that pimp you married which i don't
understand then that pempum what is that
what does that mean that pimp
that's a weird word user especially
you notice how they dotted the eye they
usually yeah the little circle yeah i
was just going to point that out
extra effort extra effort but see on
pimp they use the circle but i'm married
and the other ones they didn't use the
circle it just seems
i don't know they really liked it almost
like this was the third or fourth draft
right and they picked the word pimp with
a circle here they're like uh
pimp that's good cool right let's do it
that's right well i think maybe it took
four or five tries like wimp
um
you know who whatever whatever [ __ ]
whatever yeah right i mean if we're
going if you're going the donald trump
route then it would definitely be a wimp
or [ __ ] or something but that pimp you
mary not only broke his oath
uh he's he sold his soul i'm not sure
see if i i think a pimp wouldn't sell a
soul he would sell someone else's right
i mean you're really going to go with
the word pimp but that's that's that's
my own opinion i guess
yours and christians too and i guess
christian
is the kid right that's not a religion
that is the kid's name um which is
really [ __ ] weird when they start
addressing letters to your wife and your
kids with their names
adams so they didn't go with pemper they
went with adams his name
activities
have hurt not only this country but
countless patriotic and god-fearing
families
i guess what they mean by that is these
people been charged with crimes with
adam kinzinger didn't do that
yeah adam kinziger is allegedly he
doesn't work for the department of
justice yeah he also wasn't raising his
fist uh toward
people january 6th so right i don't
understand what he means here by he hurt
countless patriotic and god-fearing
families i don't understand what that
means i'm assuming that this person
doesn't know
you know [ __ ] anything and that
they're making the assumption that the
january 6 committee they're like the j6
committee the j6 patriots
like they're saying that he is the
reason why they are in prison right now
right that's my i'm making i'm making
just a simple assumption because they're
probably very simple-minded but if we
take that kind of very simple jump from
one point to the next it's probably
because he's on the the january 6
committee and the people that were in
prison are from january 6th so that's
probably what it is probably and then it
goes on it says therefore
although it might take time
he will be executed this is where it
gets really [ __ ] dark folks
this is where it gets really [ __ ]
dark
but don't worry
you and christian will be joining adam
in hell too so not only do they allude
to the fact that they're going to
execute
adam kinzinger but they're going to do
the same thing to his wife and his child
we will find it blasphemous that
that you name the son of the devil
christian
it really no no no no no no
no read that word right read what it
says kistian
there you go they well they forgot the
art yeah yeah well and they did this
circle thing up here at this other one
um they put a capital t and then over
here there's a c
if i'm some kind of expert which i'm not
on letters and writing
and handwriting here
this really looks like a man's writing
there's no way a woman wrote this right
no [ __ ] way women are way more
accomplished probably this is some
[ __ ] little dick boy
very upset
finding out his heroes are potentially
going to prison his other bros that he
hung out with are now in j6 political
prisoner territory i would imagine that
this person might even might even have a
ankle bracelet around their ankle and a
waiting trial somewhere possibly it
would be kind of crazy if they were
actually someone that was at the capitol
and now are awaiting trial yeah right
and they're threatening uh the person
who is
willing to out the truth right about
them seems kind of convenient so um i
mean i
i'm sure
i'm sure this person is going to get
arrested real quick and they're going to
find out you know who this person
is yeah
um
and i'm sure that uh adam kinzinger is
cooperating with law enforcement here
with this threat um again i i'm not a
everyone knows i'm not a fan of adam
kinzinger and again him telling the
truth is his duty
actually him being on the january sixth
select committee and doing what he's
doing is part of his own it is part of
his duty um just like it is everyone
else now i will agree that in today's
climate it is it is uh odd for him and
people like liz cheney
to be saying some of the things that
they're saying out loud i don't know
like um stuff that's real
um
but there is no call
there is no call for anyone to receive a
letter like this where they're naming
their wife and their children right and
them them frankly to be called to be
executed is
you know uh eric greitens-esque um in
this situation because eric greitens is
literally talking the same way in that
video we just watched
as this person in this letter folks
if you find this letter of like holy
[ __ ] this is crazy
eric greitens just said the same thing
in his little political ad that we are
coming after you if you disagree with us
adam's activities as it says here
meaning he was a he was against manga
the countless patriotic and god-fearing
families as
a maga might say that's what's happening
here that's what this is so uh i
actually i think it's a good thing that
uh adam kindergartener posted this on
twitter and i don't normally retweet him
but i did hear because i think people
need to see this the same way they need
to see that eric greitens said so
thank you adam kinzinger for this one
and and again i want everyone to know
that i think him for
doing his oath and telling the truth i
mean it seems a little ridiculous that
we have to reward these these congress
people republican or not i mean yeah
don't don't worry whether that you know
i look at the person who or i imagine
the person who sent this they were like
oh you know i'm going to write a a fake
return address and then they totally
totally ignore the fact that they submit
this letter to the usps in their local
area and it's [ __ ] stamped and they
know where they are and even if this
person were to drive to a different
location it's almost like these places
have cameras they can uh they can then
go through and scan to say who might be
a potential person that sounded like on
the list of you mean this isn't like 40
years ago when we didn't have all this
uh and then here's the other thing
unless this person of course hand
delivered this letter and put it on his
doorstep right that would be even
[ __ ] dumber
well i i i hope they i'm i'm sure by the
writing that they did something really
stupid right um so i'd imagine that
they're gonna get caught i wish i had a
really good transition other than
speaking of stupid people um you know my
great transitions you're good but i want
to show this video
because this is this is hilarious i
actually want to play this a couple
times because it's not that long but
this is
senator john kennedy of louisiana this
is a man with a fake accent yes he fakes
he he flakes hey talks you know just
like i'm just like i'm really really
digging in here
god dang goddamn woker goddamn mother
wilkers i mean he really is but listen
to the word salad i'm not really sure
who he's talking about of course they
have a a picture on fox news up here
what looks like i don't know protests
for for justice inequality and
i'm not really sure what this protest is
or what it's false church virginia on
june 9th you might be able to find it
there why what they're talking about now
because it says protesters that um
barrett's home with dolls bloody i'm not
sure what this means but listen to the
word salad that john kennedy uses to
describe people um you know how we we
figured out that
that rand paul was senator soundbyte i
believe john kennedy's going to be
senators word salad let let's listen by
the anti-intellectual
um crypto socialist woke left
by the
i'm still trying to
anti-intellectual
like literally they are always like oh
the elites they're trying to thought
jedi mind trick you chat thing with
their college and their degrees which
he's a he's a he's a [ __ ] he's a ivy
league school well you know clearly we
learn from people like ted cruz that
going to ivy league schools don't mean
[ __ ] right right what this guy knows
what he's doing here yeah no don't you
think this guy isn't [ __ ] dumb he's
[ __ ] soft jawed fake accent
um my name's last name's kennedy you
know shut the [ __ ] up okay this guy over
here
wants to throw in as many [ __ ] words
to get the 15 minute highlight that he's
got on fox news he's throwing woker now
he's throwing in crypto
what like what's like mean what is that
here's the thing what he doesn't realize
is crypto is a decentralized uh form of
currency right right if there was anyone
and i mean anyone who ever wanted
something that was outside of the
government's control that was
decentralized you mean like republicans
would want it would be the [ __ ]
republicans so he's using this word as
it's like all these woco leftists that
are using crypto no you dumb [ __ ] i
guarantee that a ton of the people that
support you or support the republican
party are into crypto because it's an
anti-government when he says crypto
though do you think he means
cryptocurrency or do you think he just
he likes the word like you know
i'm assuming
i mean the other thing to it remember
that uh you know there was
the the [ __ ] uh uh trucker convoy
was using crypto as a means of getting
around
the canadian um gofundme version of
their site so when this guy is saying
like oh it says woka these woke crypto
uh
anti-intellectuals it's like dude dude
no shut up you're talking about your own
party it's projecting right well the
thing i like about the
kennedy the word that he gave us woker
that's fantastic yeah dude absolutely i
i i actually think senator senator word
salad for the word woker because
you can't get better than that i mean
someone else who likes to make up words
um who is one of your arch-nemesis here
here here's some more really weird [ __ ]
um coming from an elected official who
nah doesn't seem to know a lot about
words let's listen in um so lauren you
were just talking um
about the idea of god calling you to run
for congress now if if somebody doesn't
believe in the god that we know
personally they just think that's looney
stuff no person what the hell does that
mean do you are you talking about trump
they got it they gotta be talking about
trump oh did they know personally get
the [ __ ] out of here what the [ __ ] i
mean like man i we're both atheists
right yeah i mean you know in the
universe that you live in when there are
people around you that are even that
even are on our same
side as far as you know political ideas
they they have faith in god or they
believe in god whether it's whether it's
a christian god or a muslim guy you know
whatever that may be
right but here these these [ __ ] bone
ends are claiming they personally know
god what the [ __ ] does that mean i don't
know i mean like it's like her next-door
neighbor she's like now he's like hey
guy just coming over to give you a nice
sweet apple pie now let's [ __ ] maybe ted
cruz convinced her he's got i don't know
but i would say he's probably donald i
mean i mean you know let's just assume
that all the money he gave her is
actually true she's like oh any any man
who gives me money is god
any man who shows me his penis in a
public bowling alley is god that might
be i think we're going to get to the
bottom of that lauren bobert story or on
top of it which i mean her her primary
look at it primaries coming up in like a
week isn't it yeah yeah i would imagine
that she's going to
lose but let's listen to what what um
um barbie [ __ ] as your stuff you
know she prayed and whatever but
you know that you're not making this up
i mean this was not an ambition of yours
when you were little this is just
something that you've fallen into but it
does seem like it is god and it seems
like you are
uh triggering your opponents
particularly well it's a joy to see
so i wanna i wanna i'm gonna bring
something up here because this is
this is this is really [ __ ] stupid
because this is where these people like
this bonehead think that there's some
kind of divine intervention from
somewhere it's this narrative that they
were elected and put here by god this
dumb [ __ ] this stupid [ __ ] like eric
greitens the texas gop basically saying
that trans people are not humans and the
lgbtq community can go [ __ ] themselves
and they are not humans they will not be
recognized in their state once they
secede because that's what they're
saying again uh texas this weekend in
their convention try to out florida
florida with rhonda sanchez's blueprint
for a fascist state they're really
trying to do the same thing but this is
this inner this this this divine
intervention thing that they're trying
to do like lauren bobert was chosen by
god like she showed up at the bowling
alley and blessed her with his
his
i don't know
and then small dick did you say what it
is small dick
but he anointed her you know he like you
know hit the shoulder and said i knight
you right
my groomer you think it's really that
it's not that big no no no it's very
small i mean it's very small it's like
you know he's he's extending it you know
kind of uh in his own mind he's like
imagine how disappointed she was when
ted cruz paid her all that money and she
found out how much
it wasn't
i mean really i mean
well the other thing too is he's like
he's like
he's like i doubt that you you were a
little kid and you decided you're gonna
run it's like no it was the point at
which she was giving [ __ ] money
and told she should run
and she probably was like oh well you're
an attractive looking person you've got
this you've got that like we give you
some money we put your name out there
you're a colleague you're from colorado
you you know you you've got your own
business these are all things that check
off the list that's so that's not easy
on the business thing easy on the
business no no no i'm saying i'm saying
at the time i'm like you know we don't
really know about the [ __ ]
that's part of some of these allegations
is that she doesn't have an actual
business because she's not paying the
proper employment tax and stuff so no
it's not a business right like the state
of colorado is gonna take her but you
might you might actually argue be like
oh yeah she actually makes a perfect
republican business owner because she
[ __ ] over her employees that's that
could be a case too she tries to uh you
know she she committed fraud she tried
to not pay off the tax lien she tried to
not pay employees benefits and uh sounds
divine to me yeah yeah anointing her
with that divine rod of god you know
let's listen
to bobo's dumb response here
yes and and you know it is it's
absolutely a sign and a wonder to the
unbeliever i i was not supposed to win
this seat i didn't have the money i
didn't have the name recognition i mean
until you did not have the money or the
name recognition until
you meant that maybe that's what you
should add there i'm just yeah yeah i
didn't have the money i was given the
money shut the [ __ ] up but
but
didn't have the education or
whatever you still don't i mean you know
because here's the thing is there's
another clip of her from this weekend
where she talks about oh i'm going to
bring it up i'm going to bring it up the
constitution and the rights and yeah
it's the same damn interview i'm going
to bring it up here i wanted to play
this one first because this one goes at
the heart of why she why she's even
running a second time in the first place
like literally you just go do the sarah
palin thing like go do that thing and
make a podcast yeah right well i mean or
go on some reality tv show i guarantee
she
when she gets
uh when she doesn't get reelected you
know in november and maybe she gets
primaried we'll see
but when she doesn't come back to her
job as representative beau bert i
guarantee
she either one tries to release a book
that well another book because she's
doing one right now but america is going
to be spelled wrong 100 percent
uh the second thing is she's going to
try to maybe start a podcast
and the third one is she's going to go
on a reality tv show because it's the
only source
like what's it gonna be called sugar
daddy summer or something i mean i mean
aaron next summer lauren we should go on
bravo tv
sugar daddy summer we should do a um
a trailer for that let's uh let's finish
when bonin has to sing here my way up
the political range she did she worked
her way up the block
that was the first time in 48 years that
an incumbent had lost a primary in
colorado and so this was absolutely a
sign and a wonder to the unbeliever uh
why does she keep saying that unbeliever
i don't know no one believes she won is
that what she's saying i think it's the
unbeliever who didn't have faith in god
and wouldn't believe that she is a woman
could take out the the incumbent
candidate
the unbeliever the person who didn't
believe in me or the fact that it was a
possibility
hmm
it's very very weird very weird also
he's like i know unbeliever's a word but
i've never used unbeliever i've always
used non-believer
right because
whatever wouldn't unbeliever mean
anyways it means the same thing it's
just a different way to say it but i
just would never say that i just say
non-believer right well here is the um
it is a different show you are correct
this is a different yeah yeah it was
like the other different trader tv yeah
this guy's even whiter than the other
guy looks like he's [ __ ] part of the
cast of uh twilight
that's how pale this guy looks he looks
like he's a [ __ ] vampire
tonight is that what this [ __ ] is
welcome to vampire tonight
like that's exactly what this is
we cannot make this [ __ ] up okay this
one's not very long but she says some
really dumb [ __ ] in this one ah who'da
guessed let's listen this guy's a
[ __ ] mannequin this guy what this guy
this guy really does look like they took
reedy giuliani's corpse and tied it to
that chair doesn't it i mean she starts
talking he's not moving he looks like
he's dead like he looks like he has been
dead for probably 12 hours
and he is just sitting there he died he
died because his his heart just failed
him because those j6 political prisoners
have been have been put in jail and the
j6 committee are coming after all these
[ __ ] traitors and his heart just
broke into two
oh
a vampire tonight lauren bobert is the
guest let's listen
so i ran because i got frustrated i saw
too many politicians giving our freedoms
away you ran because ted cruz gave you
money
get the [ __ ] out of here everyone knows
that now i i everyone keeps saying that
that's not true and they talk about that
story but really honestly if we can find
out something we can find that out we
can find that evidence and and she's
threatening to sue over that story you
know we we actually had that story on
the show when it when it broke that
morning but the threatening to sue over
that story now regardless if some of the
allegations are true or false but the
underlying allegation that ted cruz gave
her money
if she does sue that she will have to
show that in court
there will there will be discovery in
court that's why i think all this the
fox news digital article that they did
about that story
is all chess pounding all of it oh yeah
100 well yeah
i mean
have you seen the suit filed yet is
there is there a story no it's just a
letter from an attorney threatening to
see someone not i mean here's the thing
it
is
uh it is true because it there's an
article from
2020 right where it says q anon
sympathizer elected to congress failed
to disclose fundraising ties to senator
ted cruz fec says cruz gave lauren
bobert seventy thousand dollars five
seven seventy thousand five hundred
dollars on the same day that he asked
the doj to probe netflix for alleged
child porn
well you know so that story is true
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying about that that story yes some of
the pictures were wrong it seemed some
of the allegations were very salacious
right that they were pressing against
her which no one i mean everyone on the
internet went yeah so yeah i mean that
makes sense
i mean she stands in front of a
microphone and calls people who who have
abortions murderers and say abortion's
murder so if you go by the projection
standard that these [ __ ] people
continue to to have of course of course
some of those allegations in in in in
that drop of information yeah but the
but some of some of it the underlying
facts like gabe said has already been
proven before it was dropped yeah just
maybe the
it's not only that too remember it's 130
136 250 dollars in bobert's campaign
account that was transferred
from cruz and his 20 for 20 victory fun
pack and that's why i say the actual
letter from her attorney saying they're
going to sue that they sent the fox news
digital here's the thing it's all chest
pounding because he literally says in
that letter that all the allegations are
categorically false which we know that
not to be true which only makes you
think maybe all the allegations have
some underlying fact to them right so
and if there was any source that they're
like oh this isn't true it would be
based on the dollar model i guarantee
you that right semantics that they'll
argue say well this isn't true because
they got the amount right they gave her
wrong right right ted cruz still still
escorted her around texas and gave her
money to run for congress to beat an
incumbent um for what who knows what ted
who knows who knows if you had meanwhile
this guy over here is still [ __ ] dead
he is still
he is still not a living person
he seems to be in vampire purgatory or
something let's listen okay the
constitution the constitution does not
guarantee us freedom the constitution
does not get guarantee us right
wait a second wait a second wait a
second she's talking about the
constitution here
because she loves to talk about the
constitution let's let's hear what she
says about it again the constitution
does not guarantee us freedom the
constitution does not get guarantee us
rights
wait wait
surely this is a slip right this is uh
no no no
she
let's listen to it again i gotta i gotta
hear this again because she's talking
about the constitution here and i think
she loves to talk about let's listen to
it again i think when she says this the
dead guy wakes up well i you know what
she's probably trying to wake him up
maybe she's trying to say crazy
hey honey i think he's dead i think he's
dead maybe i should say some crazy [ __ ]
to get him to wake up let's listen
the constitution the constitution does
not guarantee us freedom the
constitution does not get guarantee us
rights it is there too but but you
noticed you noticed
yeah she woke up right it did it did
kind of shake him a little bit but he
didn't he didn't i mean if i was
listening to a guest and we had a guest
on especially if it was lauren bobert
which lauren you're welcome on the show
ollie yeah come on the show
we would love to ask you a ton of
questions i got a ton of questions i'd
love to ask you but if she were to say
something like that on the show i
wouldn't just be like
i mean it would i'd be like whoa
constitution doesn't guarantee what yeah
what what do you believe her words
literally resurrected this dude from the
dead
because now he moves in the chair and
goes well i'm sorry what was that what
would she say but he doesn't even
correct her he just goes oh [ __ ] he's
just shaking his head yeah he was like
oh man watch when he slumbers from his
his dirt nap here to guarantee that
those rights are protected these are our
god-given rights these are unalienable
and uh they are uh from uh
these are our natural laws
so they're not guaranteed but they're
get i don't know what does he do he just
goes like this he goes through him yeah
he's like yeah yeah he just keeps
nodding his head which i don't know if
like he's slowly coming back like into
being animated because he just was like
stuck in this state of being dead
but
i do have to wonder
you know if if he let it go too far and
didn't correct it he's like oh [ __ ] and
i can't do [ __ ] about it i gotta let her
keep going
i wonder if she feels this way this this
little part right here i wonder if she
feels this way right here
about the second amendment right here
the constitution does not guarantee us
freedom the constitution does not get
guarantee us rights oh the constitution
does not guarantee his rights
that second amendment right she's always
talk i mean the only one she can ever
talk about is the second amendment when
she don't even know what the [ __ ] it
says but you heard it right here folks
on the tony michaels podcast and lauren
bobert if you're listening out there
which i know you probably are
i don't know she probably doesn't listen
to the show but if she does lauren or
one of your staff members or something
if you're listening to the show come on
i would love to ask you about how you do
not think that the second amendment and
the constitution does not grant you that
right of the second amendment
the funniest part about this is like you
know literally the beginning of the
constitution you have the bill of rights
the bill of rights
of rights
rights
which are the first 10
to the constitution which which
guarantee you she says it in the world
it doesn't guarantee you freedom it
doesn't guarantee it actually does
exactly the bill of rights literally
guarantees you civil rights and
liberties to the individual
like the first amendment or the second
amendment or the third fourth and the
fifth amendment that you know and
obviously you don't know anything beyond
that but the
[ __ ] rights we're getting dumber man
it's getting dumber
the bill of rights
the constitution does not grant you that
bill of rights of which you see with
your eyes and your ears do not let them
fool you i want to leave the following
fathers with just like a quick word with
lauren and the dead guy maybe that you
know what maybe that guy
is one of the people who were like in
the signing room with the founding
fathers and he's just been dead this
whole time and then she made this claim
he's like oh [ __ ] what oh [ __ ] and then
she said it and then he was like slowly
processing to be like wait did she say
what i think she said
yeah she said what she and then that's
why he's nodding so he's like not
agreeing with her but he's like nodding
like yeah she said that dumb thing she
did she did but he's like too slow
to come back and be like no no no no you
don't understand how the constitution
works or the bill of rights that are
that's in the constitution
he i'm sure he didn't challenge her on
that at all oh no
i honestly think
he let it go too far
and it was the point of no return he
could not then 30 seconds after like
wait wait wait wait wait you just said
what
you wouldn't do that yeah well
oh it gets it's it's getting dumber and
dumber by the day and i'm sure tomorrow
we're gonna see a lot of evidence of
dumb
um when we watch the hearings tomorrow
gabe you know
we are producing the hearings for midas
touch and tomorrow
at the exact time that we start our show
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific we
will be doing the coverage for midas
touch for hearing day number four the
the most exciting part about it
is apparently the arizona former speaker
of the arizona republican party is going
to be showing up to testify probably not
happy about it also brad rathersberger
is supposed to be there as well to talk
about georgia which i think is very
significant in criminal charges that
could be brought against trump and then
his uh you guys remember the deputy
right
the deputy who gave the big press
conference that chastised the president
and said you're going to get someone
killed we played it a couple weeks ago
but
he's going to be there tomorrow as well
on testifying in front of the hearing
the select hearing um so check that out
make sure you you go over to midas touch
youtube channel um do not forget to go
set a reminder over there and subscribe
to my such youtube channel again don't
forget why you're on our channel to
subscribe to our channel the tony
michaels podcast we bring you
every single weekday two hours monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific right here on youtube
twitter and twitch so subscribe and also
go download every single episode
on the your favorite podcast directory
rather be google spotify
apple or any other directory you can
download every single podcast
and don't forget to follow us on twitter
as well at tony michael's pod
it is almost it's the end of the show
man time flew
it's just two hours goes by fast it does
it goes by really fast i do want i do
have a great video i want to show we had
a lot of
dumb in our videos today and a lot of
fascists in our videos today but i do
want to show you something that is truly
inspiring here um you guys remember
gabby giffords years ago during a
campaign
when she was campaigning for congress
she was actually shot in the head
by someone who was able to obtain a gun
and she's been working
diligently ever since since she survived
that incident to work for gun reform and
gun safety um but the the greatest part
is is that gabby actually and here is a
a video of her throwing out the first
pitch at a red sox game this is
inspiration to everyone out there should
be inspiration everyone out there that
even even in the toughest of times i
mean gabby could have totally
um after her injuries after surviving
her injuries could have went into
privacy and made sure that she wasn't a
public figure and just lived what what
the life she had but she has made it
her mission to be out there in public
her husband
is uh senator kelly uh mark kelly and
he's going to be re-running this year in
the midterm
but
this is inspirational that gabby
giffords could even stand on the mound
and pitch this ball so everyone i want
to finish the the
the show today with a great video a
gabby giffords throwing up the first
pitch for the red sox take a look
what an inspiration
to all americans
she can not only
survive the violence that um was brought
on her that day but to come out with a
positive attitude and try to help other
americans
to prevent gun violence that was the
same type of gun violence that was
brought on her and uh gabe i know you're
gonna do a what was that um about the
hearings but you know what i'd like to
see i'm putting in a request here
because we've had some new news speaking
of gun violence from the uvalde school
oh yeah and an update so if you get a
chance i know you got a lot on your list
over there for the world
but as you're making four or five of
these a day yeah yeah we should we
really should do a an update on from the
first because i believe that was one of
the first ones you did that was the that
was the first one yeah that was
basically
yeah the evolution had a lot of evidence
so yeah yeah yeah and you know there's
there you know i definitely would like
to do a good guy bad guy you know gun
situation uh maybe but
because we know that some of the news
that's come out of that that there may
have not been there's so that might be a
that might be a portion of this as i lay
out the timeline to basically say like
these guys were incompetent and idiots
and they did nothing despite the
training
and uh you know every day that they
speak they make
their own story even worse right well
let's let's let's do this let's remember
gabby gifford's video there and the
fight for gun reform and it's up to you
folks just like gabby fought um to stand
on that mound and throw that pitch it is
up to you democracy is hard but we can
all do it with pro as long as we're
pushing pro democracy ideas so tomorrow
do the pro-democracy thing and come
listen to the truth of the january 6
select hearings again we will be
broadcasting from the midas touch
youtube channel go over and subscribe
click the bell notification for that
video right now day four
of the january 6 select hearings do not
forget to set your reminder tomorrow we
will start our coverage an hour before
the gavel goes down at noon eastern 11
central nine pacific until then
gabe and audience
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking